what do you think of Nickelodeon we're
fans but we can't help but feel that
there's something wrong with the station
we think that it has seen better days
and we want something to be done about
it be sure to stay at the end because
there's two words Nickelodeon needs to
bear in mind so it can be the station we
know it can be if you haven't visited
the things before then do us a favor
give this video a thumbs up and hit the
subscribe button today we're going to
talk about everything wrong with
Nickelodeon if we're going to look at
what's wrong with Nickelodeon that it's
only fair and it's only sensible if we
take a look at what used to be right
with it back in the 1980s the 1990s and
the 2000s it was the go-to channel for
any child with an interest in watching
TV pretty much 90% of classic American
and Canadian kids television from that
era was on Nickelodeon and it was a big
part of a lot of people's lives growing
up but now it's less so one of the
problems that a lot of people have with
it is how repetitive the programming is
listen we love Sponge Bob Squarepants we
really do
the thing is though we don't quite love
it so much that it's the only thing we
want to watch ever and sometimes
Nickelodeon can feel a bit like that
there's a reliance on repeats of that
show that it can be a bit like eating a
10-pound bag of candy it's great but you
can't help but feel that it's all a bit
too much now we'll admit that
Nickelodeon isn't the only channel with
this problem the same sort of thing can
be said about how much cartoon network
broadcast Teen Titans go for instance so
we think we'd rather watch Spongebob
Squarepants than Teen Titans go but that
isn't the point firstly just because
another channel is making a mistake
there's no reason for Nickelodeon to
make pretty much the same one secondly
Sponge Bob Squarepants started in 1999
while Teen Titans go premiered in 2013
so there's actually more of a likelihood
that people will be more familiar and
familiarity can sadly breed contempt
with nickelodeon show than Cartoon
Network's it's a bit too much like
SpongeBob SquarePants is Nickelodeon and
Nickelodeon is SpongeBob SquarePants
what we would suggest is that
Nickelodeon should maybe start to mix up
its programming a bit more ideally we'd
love for it to start making shows that
will become classics again but that may
not be strictly necessary at least in
the short term it could delve back into
40 years of great children's television
and introduce some classic shows to a
whole new generation
either way we think that a freshening up
of this
is something that's needed because
relying on one show no matter how
brilliant and iconic it may be is a
recipe for disaster people are always
looking for a bit of variety and that's
something that we think is a little bit
lacking from Nickelodeon schedules
another thing that didn't help the way
things were going for the channel with
the closure of Nickelodeon magazine in
2009 the magazine itself was really
popular it wasn't just tie-in after
tie-in they were interesting and
informative pieces that were relevant to
children an issue might contain some
cool recipes or an enlightening piece of
nonfiction writing but regardless of
that it did something else it grew the
brand now Nickelodeon wasn't just
something that kept young kids
entertained on the television it was
something that enriched their lives and
maybe got them into reading too so that
in turn meant that parents might be a
little more welcoming towards the
channel and it also meant that children
were more inclined to develop a kind of
brand loyalty to the station and its
offshoots people talked about how the
magazine which came out every month and
was heavily advertised actually
kick-started a lifelong love of reading
however declining sales and a tendency
for old school media to make more use of
online sounded the death Knoll for the
magazine so it closed in 2009 however
nothing really took its place parents
who were fine with letting their
offspring read a magazine were somewhat
wary about letting their kids loose on
the internet and checking out the
Nickelodeon website so while the site
had hits there would have been people
who read the printed product and never
migrated online it looked as if
Nickelodeon magazine would be reborn in
2015 but it wasn't the same and that
closed after less than a year did you
know that members of the public used to
be able to go into the Nickelodeon
studios that's right and that was also a
part of the channel success they were
located in Orlando Florida USA and they
were part of the station's iconography
back when the channel used to host a lot
of things like game shows and shows
filmed in front of a live studio
audience being part of the Universal
Studios theme park didn't do it any harm
either if you were a kid on holiday in
the area the chances were that you would
swing by the Nickelodeon studios while
you were there and you'd get the chance
to see shows being made and that meant
that you'd feel a connection with the
channel but by the time the early
noughties rolled around things were
sadly different there was a move away
from the likes of Clarissa explains it
all super sloppy double dare we nerville
and what would you do to programs that
required a closed set to make it wasn't
just a TV station it was a place
could check out an experience while you
were on vacation too if you are lucky
enough to go to Nickelodeon studios
you'll know exactly what we're talking
about but sadly it closed in 2005 and
now stands home to the Blue Man Group of
performers but nothing is replaced it we
know exactly how powerful the link
between a place and a media brand can be
so kids today aren't lucky enough to be
able to dream of paying a visit to
Nickelodeon studios for them Nickelodeon
is just another TV station showing some
programs they like there's no world
building while we know TV has changed
since the 1990s here's an idea
bring back the idea of the Nickelodeon
studios it just might work
perhaps one of Nickelodeon's biggest
mistakes can be illustrated using just
one show back in the 1990's Doug was a
big deal for kids across the US and
Canada the tales of every kid character
Doug funnie his crush on Patti
mayonnaise and life in the town of
bluffington entertained kids and charmed
adults too you know Charlie Brown from
the peanuts cartoons the character of
Doug was a bit like him he was the
lovable down-on-his-luck type and when
it was launched it joined Rugrats and
the ren & stimpy show as one of
Nickelodeon's very first original
cartoons now despite being popular and
well-received critically nickelodeon
declined to renew it in 1993 saying that
it was too expensive to make
so once the contract ran out the show's
creator Jim Jenkins decided that if
Nickelodeon didn't want it then someone
else should that someone was Disney
that's right
Nickelodeon allowed a highly popular
show first to stop being made then when
they could have taken a break and just
made fewer episodes they allowed the
Creator to move it on so what happened
was that one of Nickelodeon's biggest
rivals got one of the station's most
popular shows when you think about it
it's pretty rare that a program changes
networks but Nickelodeon allowed it to
happen we're sure that Jim Jenkins might
well have allowed more Doug to be made
even if it was at a slower pace it shows
a channel that is willing to let
something that entertains viewers and
keeps them watching to wither away so if
you remember Doug and you loved it
you might not be able to quite pinpoint
which channel it was on it's that thing
about brand loyalty again if you aren't
100% sure which station a show was on
then you might not feel the same way
about the station it was on if you see
what we mean when people think of
Nickelodeon there's one thing that quite
often pops into their heads can you
guess what that might be
well the thing
we're thinking of right now is that
classic logo it's orange it's got white
writing and it's shaped like a range of
things but mainly a splatter when the
station was first set up in the late
1970s it went through a whole range of
different logos as it started to find
its own identity incidentally did you
know that the station wasn't originally
called Nickelodeon when it was first set
up in 1977 it was called pinwheel after
the show for preschoolers that was a
staple of its programming
it wasn't until 1979 that it got the
name we all know and love today but it
wasn't until 1985 the iconic logo came
into being
unfortunately it changed to a more
pointed stylized logo in 2009 that might
sound like a minor thing but it really
isn't you see there was a certain sort
of genius in the classic Nickelodeon
logo when designers Tom Cory and Scott
Nash designed it they deliberately made
it Orange that's because orange clashes
with pretty much every other color so
they wanted it to stand out from the
crowd and the splat could be turned into
pretty much everything that you wanted
this fit in with the essence of variety
that Nickelodeon brought to the table
interestingly Network bosses wanted to
rebrand the station as nic with people
responsible for ordering the logo put
their feet down they thought it sounded
too much like a garage mechanic but the
logo kind of fit in with a Golden Age of
American kids TV and again it brought
about brand loyalty people knew what the
logo was what it meant and what it was
associated with the creative team behind
commissioning the logo didn't want to
tell people that the station was fun
they wanted it to be fun and the logo
was part of that now let's be honest
here do you get that from the current
Nickelodeon logo we don't a will bet
that it doesn't sit in people's hearts
and minds in the way that the old one
did either so yet again there was
something that fostered a kind of
loyalty towards the Nickelodeon brand in
a way that the current one doesn't we
suggest a return to the old logo
it was the station's echos exemplified
we also need to have a little mention of
the key thing about what makes any TV
channel great does shows Nickelodeon as
we have seen has more than enough great
examples of those when you think about
some of the great programs that it used
to show back in the day not just the big
hitters like Kenan and Kel Larissa
explains it all and the Ren and Stimpy
show but also its wide range of game
shows you think of quality and you think
of Nickelodeon well there are still some
great shows being made we absolutely
adore the loud-ass and we
you do too there's a lot of things
coming through too and for all the
latest generation of young minds in any
great volume part of that might be down
to a lot of talent coming true but it
might be more likely that there's a lack
of willingness to take risks the sort of
risks that will get people to develop a
brand loyalty towards Nickelodeon we
aren't saying these things because we
hate Nickelodeon and we don't care what
happens to it we're saying these things
because we love Nickelodeon at least we
love what it used to be we want other
people to love it too it doesn't take
much all it needs is for someone to
expand what the channel does and use
those things as a way to bring up that
brand loyalty just think of how many
things outside of TV and film you can
associate with for example Disney and
you'll know what we're talking about but
we think we might have spoken for too
long enough do you think there are
things wrong with Nickelodeon and if so
how would you fix them don't be shy go
ahead and let us know what it is that
you think in the comments and that's it
for everything wrong with Nickelodeon if
you liked it then check out five cartoon
reboots that are way better than the
original thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe